ברוכים הבאים חזרה להבנת מידע קוונטי וחישוב, שמי John Watrous ואני המנהל
הטכני לחינוך ב-IBM Quantum. זהו השיעור השמיני בסדרה והשיעור האחרון ב
יחידה השנייה של הסדרה שעוסקת באלגוריתמים קוונטיים. דיברנו על מודל השאילתות של חישוב כולל אלגוריתמים
קוונטיים שמציעים יתרון מוכח על אלגוריתמים קלאסיים בתוך המודל הזה. דנו במושגים בסיסיים הקשורים ל
אלגוריתמים קוונטיים ואיך אפשר למדוד עלות חישובית, ובשיעור הקודם דנו בהערכת פאזה ובאלגוריתם של
Shor. בשיעור הזה נדון באלגוריתם של Grover שמספק יתרון ריבועי של קוונטי על
אלגוריתמים קלאסיים לבעיות חיפוש כביכול לא-מובנות, שאתאר ברגע שניכנס ל
שיעור. כל אלה נושאים בסיסיים הנוגעים לאלגוריתמים קוונטיים. יש אלגוריתמים קוונטיים
נוספים וגם פרדיגמות כלליות שמאחדות אלגוריתמים קוונטיים שונים וטכניקות אלגוריתמיות קוונטיות, ו
אם מעניין אתכם אני מעודד אתכם לבדוק את גן החיות של אלגוריתמים קוונטיים שמסווג אלגוריתמים קוונטיים ידועים וכולל הפניות רבות
למאמרי מחקר מקוריים שתרמו לפיתוחם. אבל בסדרה הזו
אנחנו רק הולכים להישאר עם היסודות, ומהשיעור הבא נעבור לנושא חדש. אבל
קודם בואו נדבר על אלגוריתם Grover. הנה סקירת השיעור. נתחיל עם דיון קצר על
הבעיה החישובית שנתייחס אליה, שהיא חיפוש לא-מובנה. באופן אינטואיטיבי אפשר
לחשוב על בעיית החיפוש הלא-מובנה כחיפוש באוסף של פריטים שלא ממוין ולא סודר בצורה
שימושית. אז נדון באלגוריתם Grover שהוא אלגוריתם קוונטי שמציע יתרון ריבועי על
אלגוריתמים קלאסיים, וניכנס בדיוק למה זה אומר בקרוב. תיאור ברמה גבוהה מאוד של
איך האלגוריתם הזה עובד הוא שקודם יש שלב אתחול ואז פעולה שאקרא לה פעולת
Grover חוזרת מספר מסוים של פעמים, ולבסוף מתבצעת מדידה שחושפת מועמד
לפתרון לבעיית החיפוש. אסביר מהי פעולת Grover ואיך אפשר
לממש אותה על מחשב קוונטי, ואז נעבור על ניתוח של הפעולה הזו כדי להבין טוב יותר מה היא עושה ולמה היא שימושית ל
חיפוש. החלק השלישי של השיעור עוסק במספר האיטרציות
באלגוריתם Grover, או במילים אחרות מספר הפעמים שצריך להפעיל את פעולת Grover בהנחה שאנחנו רוצים
למקסם את הסבירות שהאלגוריתם מצליח למצוא את מה שאנחנו מחפשים ובו-זמנית למזער את
העלות. נתחיל עם בעיית החיפוש היחיד שהיא מקרה מיוחד שבו יש בדיוק פתרון אחד לבעיית
החיפוש שלנו, ואז נשקול מה קורה כשיש מספר פתרונות. ולבסוף אסיים את
השיעור עם כמה הערות קצרות על אלגוריתם Grover וההכללות שלו. נתחיל עם
הבעיה החישובית שנתייחס אליה לאורך השיעור. ראשית, כמו שאנחנו עושים לעיתים קרובות,
ניתן לסיגמא לסמן את האלף-בית הבינארי, ונשתמש בסימון הזה לכל אורך השיעור אז לא אמשיך
להזכיר לכם. נניח שיש לנו פונקציה f שממפה מחרוזות בינאריות באורך כלשהו n ל
אלף-בית הבינארי. ההנחה שלנו היא שאפשר בקלות להעריך את הפונקציה הזו. ל
דוגמה אולי יש לנו circuit בוליאני לפונקציה הזו שגודלו פולינומיאלי ב-N. עכשיו, זה לא אומר שזו
בהכרח פונקציה פשוטה במובן כלשהו, או שיש לנו הבנה טובה במיוחד של הפונקציה הזו. למשל אולי יש לנו
circuit בוליאני די מסובך ומבולגן לחישוב F שמאפשר לנו להעריך אותה על מחרוזות קלט שונות אבל לא בהכרח בעל
צורה נחמדה שנועדה להקל על חיינו. המטרה שלנו היא למצוא פתרון, ובזה
הכוונה למחרוזת בינארית באורך N שגורמת ל-F להתחשב ל-1. באופן כללי זו בעיה חישובית
מאוד קשה, או לפחות אנחנו חושדים שהיא מאוד קשה. בפרט, אם הקלט הוא למעשה
תיאור של circuit בוליאני לחישוב הפונקציה f, אז זו בעיה כביכול NP-שלמה. דרך אחת
שאפשר לפרמל את הבעיה הזו היא כבעיית שאילתות, ואכן לצורכי השיעור הזה סביר
לחשוב על הבעיה הזו אך ורק בהקשר של מודל השאילתות. אבל כשחושבים על איפה או מתי הבעיה
הזו עשויה לעלות בפרקטיקה, ניתן לטעון שיותר טבעי לחשוב על F כמחושבת על ידי circuit
בוליאני. כפי שראינו בשיעור 6, אפשר לחבר בין שתי נקודות המבט האלה דרך הבנייה שעברנו עליה כדי לקחת circuit בוליאני ו
להמיר אותו ל-circuit קוונטי למימוש פעולת שאילתה או gate שאילתה. בכל מקרה, מבחינה מושגית
הקלט לבעיה הוא הפונקציה f ואנחנו מחפשים פתרון אם יש כזה, ואם
אין פתרון, כלומר ש-F מתבררת כפונקציית האפס הקבועה, אז הפלט הנכון הוא לדווח
שאין פתרונות. זו בעיית חיפוש לא-מובנה במובן שאין
שום דבר מיוחד ב-F שמקל על מציאת פתרון. זה לא כאילו אנחנו מחפשים
דרך נתונים שכבר סודרו או שנטענו למבנה נתונים כלשהו שמקל על חיפוש, ואין הבטחה על
הפונקציה f שעשויה לעזור לנו. דרך אחת לחשוב על זה היא שזה כמו לחפש מספר טלפון מסוים
בספר טלפונים, בניגוד לחיפוש שם שהוא הרבה יותר קל בהנחה שהשמות
סודרו לפי סדר אלפביתי. במונחים פרקטיים זה לא באמת על חיפוש דרך נתונים
שאנחנו נוטים לארגן ולאחסן בצורה שמקלה על חיפוש. זה יותר מייצג חיפוש אחר
פתרון למשוואה מסובכת למשל, או אולי חיפוש אחר הקומבינציה שפותחת
מנעול. כהערת אגב, הגיוני לחשוב על הבעיה הזו בהקשר של מודל השאילתות ללא קשר לאיך שאנחנו
מרגישים לגבי הרלוונטיות הפרקטית של המודל הזה. כמובן שאין אורקלים או קופסאות שחורות בחיים האמיתיים, אבל עד ש
נלמד אחרת, circuit-ים בוליאניים מסובכים ומסתוריים הם מעין קופסאות
שחורות. עכשיו בואו נחשוב על אלגוריתמים לפתרון בעיית החיפוש הלא-מובנה הזו, ואנחנו הולכים לעשות את זה
במודל השאילתות פשוט לשם פשטות. אם יש לנו circuit בוליאני לפונקציה שלנו במקום קופסה שחורה,
אז עדיין אפשר להריץ אלגוריתמי שאילתות עליו, אבל כמובן שאי אפשר לשלול את האפשרות שאלגוריתם חדש כלשהו
יתגלה לבעיה הזו שלא מבוסס על ביצוע שאילתות, אבל לא נטריד את עצמנו עם
האפשרות הזו. קודם כל קצת סימונים. מספר מחרוזות הקלט הכולל לפונקציה f הוא 2 בחזקת
n קטנה כאשר n קטנה היא אורך מחרוזות הקלט ל-F, ומכאן ואילך אני אתן ל-N גדולה להיות המספר הזה, 2 בחזקת
n קטנה. זה די נפוץ שאנשים משתמשים באות גדולה כזו כדי לסמן 2 בחזקת הגרסה הקטנה
של אותה אות. אנחנו הולכים לדבר על המספר N גדולה לא מעט אז זה סתם הולך להיות
נוח ויעזור לשמור על דברים קצת יותר מסודרים. ושוב, הסימון הזה תקף לכל
אורך השיעור. עכשיו, כמובן שאפשר לפתור את בעיית החיפוש באופן קלאסי על ידי פשוט
מעבר על כל מחרוזות ה-n ביטים האפשריות בכל סדר שנבחר, והערכת F על כל אחת
מהן. אם מוצאים פתרון בשלב כלשהו אפשר לעצור, אבל במקרה הגרוע נגיע להעריך את F על כל
מחרוזת קלט בודדת. אז זה דורש N, כלומר N
גדולה, שאילתות. היינו יכולים לבחור למדוד את עלות החישוב הזה בדרך אחרת, לא רק במונחים של מספר השאילתות, אבל מספר השאילתות
מייצג את מספר הפעמים שצריך להעריך את הפונקציה f, וסביר לצפות שההערכות של f ישלטו בעלות
של החישוב הזה. זה למעשה הכי טוב שאפשר לעשות עם אלגוריתם דטרמיניסטי,
ושוב זה בהקשר של מודל השאילתות. אם שאלנו על כל
מחרוזת קלט חוץ מאחת ו-F קיבלה ערך אפס על כולן עד כה, איך אפשר להיות בטוחים שהמחרוזת
האחרונה היא לא פתרון? והתשובה היא שאי אפשר. אז כן צריך את כל N השאילתות במקרה
הגרוע. אפשר גם להשתמש באקראיות, שיכולה להציע שיפורים מינוריים מאוד כמו הקטנת
מספר השאילתות הצפוי שנדרש למציאת פתרון כשקיים כזה, או שאפשר למעשה להחליף הסתברות
נכונות בהפחתת שאילתות. אבל איך שלא מסתכלים על זה, עדיין נצטרך מספר שאילתות שהוא לינארי
ב-N. אז מבחינה קלאסית אנחנו צריכים מספר לינארי של שאילתות, כלומר לינארי
ב-N גדולה. אלגוריתם Grover הוא אלגוריתם קוונטי לחיפוש שעושה את זה טוב יותר. הוא דורש רק O גדול של
שורש N שאילתות. השאילתות האלה מתבצעות בסופרפוזיציה אז זה לא קסם, אבל
זה שיפור משמעותי על מה שאפשרי באופן קלאסי, וזה מה שנקרא יתרון
ריבועי. האם היתרון הריבועי הזה של קוונטי על קלאסי יכול להפוך ליתרון ממשי במובן
פרקטי? כנראה שלא בזמן הקרוב, אבל בעתיד הרחוק מי יודע. אבל גם אם
אלגוריתם Grover לעולם לא יוביל ליתרון פרקטי בחיפוש, הוא בכל זאת חלק חשוב מ
היסודות של אלגוריתמים קוונטיים ששווה מאוד להבין. לפני שנעבור לאלגוריתם Grover עצמו, צריך
לדבר בקצרה על מה שנקרא gate-י שאילתת פאזה. אלגוריתמים קוונטיים רבים במודל השאילתות מבוטאים באופן טבעי
באמצעות gate-י שאילתת פאזה, ונראה שאלגוריתם Grover הוא דוגמה
ספציפית. נתחיל עם מבט מהיר על gate-י שאילתה רגילים עבור פונקציה f מ
הסוג שדיברנו עליו. gate השאילתה UF מוגדר על מצבי בסיס סטנדרטי כפי שמוצג על
המסך, ולסופרפוזיציות של מצבי בסיס סטנדרטי הפעולה נקבעת על ידי לינאריות. ושווה להזכיר
לעצמנו שמ-circuit בוליאני עבור f אפשר למעשה לבנות circuit לפעולה הזו UF בעלות ש
לינארית בגודל ה-circuit הבוליאני. gate שאילתת הפאזה עבור f מצד שני, שנסמן בשם
ZF, פועל ככה. בפרט ה-gate הזה פועל על
n qubit-ים קטנה, בניגוד ל-n קטנה פלוס 1 qubit-ים, והוא בעצם פשוט בועט אוטומטית את ערך הפונקציה
לתוך הפאזה במקום לעשות XOR של ערך הפלט על qubit נוסף כמו שיש לנו
עבור UF. אז אם חושבים על מה קורה כשמשתמשים ב-Phase Kickback על gate UF,
אנחנו בעצם פשוט מממשים gate ZF. צריך מצב minus וזה עולה הערכה אחת
של UF, אבל כן מקבלים את מצב ה-minus בחזרה ואפשר להשתמש בו לפעם הבאה אם רוצים, או ש
אפשר פשוט לזרוק אותו. אז זה מה שgate שאילתת פאזה הוא. עכשיו אם פשוט
ניתן לנו gate שאילתת פאזה ZF וזו הדרך היחידה שיש לנו גישה לפונקציה f, אז אי אפשר באמת
לשחזר gate UF. אבל אם יש לנו גרסה מבוקרת של ZF, אז כן אפשר
לבנות gate UF, ואשאיר את זה לכם כ
תרגיל. בנוסף ל-gate שאילתת הפאזה עבור הפונקציה f, אנחנו גם הולכים להצטרך gate שאילתת פאזה עבור פונקציית ה-OR על n ביטים,
או במילים אחרות הפונקציה שמקבלת ערך אפס כשנותנים לה את המחרוזת כולה-אפסים ואחרת היא
מקבלת ערך 1. ובאופן מפורש, הדרך ש-Zor פועל על מצבי בסיס סטנדרטי מוצגת
כאן על המסך. ה-gate הזה לא תלוי בפונקציה f, אז הוא לא דורש
שום שאילתות. ודרך אחת שאפשר לבנות circuit קוונטי שמממש את הפעולה הזו היא לעשות משהו
דומה למה שעשינו עבור הפונקציה f, חוץ מזה שמתחילים עם circuit בוליאני שמחשב את פונקציית OR על
n ביטים. ועכשיו שיש לנו את ה-gate-ים האלה אנחנו מוכנים לעבור לחלק
הבא. עכשיו נדון באלגוריתם Grover, ונתחיל עם תיאור של האלגוריתם. מתחילים באתחול
n qubit-ים קטנה, כל אחד למצב plus, או במילים אחרות שמים את ה-qubit-ים האלה בסופרפוזיציה שווה של כל
מחרוזות הבינאריות באורך n. מה שאנחנו הולכים לעשות הוא למעשה לכוון את מצב ה-qubit-ים האלה
לכיוון פתרון, אז אינטואיטיבי שמתחילים במצב הזה כי אנחנו עדיין לא יודעים כלום על הפונקציה f.
בשלב הזה כל מחרוזת סבירה באותה מידה להיות פתרון, וזה משתקף בעובדה שה-qubit-ים האלה בסופרפוזיציה שווה של כל
המחרוזות. ואז חוזרים, מפעילים שוב ושוב את פעולת Grover שהיא באמת הלב של
האלגוריתם, ואתאר אותה עוד רגע. מפעילים את הפעולה הזו סך הכול T פעמים כאשר T הוא מספר שלם לא-שלילי
כלשהו, אבל המספר הזה לא מצוין על ידי האלגוריתם עצמו. צריך לבחור T איכשהו, ובחלק
הבא נדבר על בחירות טובות ל-T. אבל לעת עתה אפשר לחשוב על מספר האיטרציות T כ
שרירותי. ולבסוף מודדים בבסיס הסטנדרטי וזה נותן לנו
פתרון מועמד. אין ערובה שזה באמת פתרון, אבל אם בוחרים T היטב אז
ההסתברות לקבל פתרון יכולה להיעשות גדולה. והנה פעולת Grover
עצמה שקראנו לה G. זו הרכבה של פעולות, כולן על n qubit-ים, אז זו פעולה על n
qubit-ים. קודם יש gate ZF, או במילים אחרות gate שאילתת פאזה עבור
פונקציית הקלט f, ואחריו שכבה של gate-י Hadamard, ואז יש Zor שהוא gate שאילתת הפאזה עבור פונקציית
OR, ולבסוף עוד שכבה של gate-י Hadamard. אז רואים שאיטרציה אחת בשלב
2 ניתנת למימוש על ידי circuit בצורה שמוצגת כאן על המסך, וכאן יש לנו 4 qubit-ים אגב,
אבל באופן כללי יכול להיות כל מספר של qubit-ים. דבר מפתח לשים לב אליו כאן הוא שצריך שאילתה אחת של f כדי לממש G.
צריך שאילתה אחת כדי לממש ZF ולאף אחת מהפעולות האחרות אין תלות ב-F, אז הן לא דורשות שאילתות. אז המספר T הזה ש
מייצג את מספר הפעמים שמפעילים G בשלב 2 מייצג גם את מספר השאילתות שאנחנו
צריכים. הנה דרך טיפוסית שבה אפשר להשתמש באלגוריתם Grover, אבל זו בהחלט לא הדרך היחידה. כמו שאמרתי
קודם, הדבר הראשון שצריך לעשות הוא לבחור T, וניכנס לזה בחלק הבא.
לכל T שנבחר מריצים את אלגוריתם Grover ל-T איטרציות ומקבלים פתרון מועמד
X. אין ערובה ש-X הוא באמת פתרון, אבל אפשר להוציא שאילתה נוספת אחת כדי לבדוק. אם יש לנו פתרון אז אפשר
לפלוט את הפתרון ולעצור, ואחרת אפשר לנסות שוב אולי עם בחירה אחרת של T
אבל לא בהכרח, או שאפשר לוותר ולדווח שאין פתרונות. כמו שאמרתי קודם, זו
לא הדרך היחידה שבה אפשר להשתמש באלגוריתם, אבל זו דרך טבעית ליישם אותו על בעיית החיפוש. עכשיו נראה מה פעולת
Grover באמת עושה למצב ה-n qubit-ים שהיא פועלת עליהם. נחשוב על ה-n qubit-ים שלנו כ
יוצרים רגיסטר בודד שאקרא לו Q רק כדי לבחור שם. זכרו שמה שעושים קודם ב
אלגוריתם Grover הוא להכניס את Q לסופרפוזיציה אחידה של כל מחרוזות ה-n ביטים, ועושים את זה על ידי הפעלת gate-י Hadamard
על n qubit-ים במצב כולו-אפסים. אז חוזרים על פעולת Grover G ואז
מודדים. זה הולך להיות מועיל לחלק את קבוצת כל מחרוזות ה-n ביטים לשתי קבוצות, A0 ו
A1. A0 מכילה את כל המחרוזות שגורמות ל-F להתחשב ל-0, ו-A1 מכילה את כל המחרוזות שגורמות ל-F
להתחשב ל-1. דרך אחרת לומר את זה היא ש-A1 מכילה את כל הפתרונות לבעיית
החיפוש שלנו, בעוד A0 מכילה את כל מה שאינו פתרון. נתעניין במיוחד
בשני מצבים קוונטיים. אחד הוא הסופרפוזיציה האחידה על כל מה שאינו פתרון, זה ket A0, ו
השני הוא אחיד על כל הפתרונות וזה ket A1. צריך לציין שההגדרות האלה הגיוניות רק
כשהקבוצות האלה לא ריקות, כי אחרת אנחנו סוכמים אפס דברים ומחלקים באפס. וככל ש
נעבור על הניתוח הזה של אלגוריתם Grover נעשה את ההנחה הזו. אפשר בקלות רבה להבין מה
אלגוריתם Grover עושה כש-f היא או פונקציית האפס הקבועה או פונקציית האחד הקבועה, על ידי התייחסות אליהן כמקרים מיוחדים, אבל אשאיר את זה
לכם לעשות לבד. לא מפתיע, אם כל מחרוזת היא פתרון אנחנו אכן נקבל
פתרון כשנמדוד, ואם אין פתרונות אז לא נקבל כזה כי במקרה הזה אין
פתרונות. אבל לצורך הניתוח הזה אנחנו הולכים להניח ששתי הקבוצות האלה לא ריקות, כך שהגדרות
שני המצבים האלה הגיוניות. אגב, זה סימון די נפוץ:
בכל פעם שיש לנו קבוצה סופית לא-ריקה S אפשר לכתוב ket S כדי לסמן את הסופרפוזיציה האחידה על
אלמנטי הקבוצה, בדיוק כמו שיש לנו כאן. אז בואו נאסוף את ההגדרות האלה ככה ונראה איך הן מתחברות
לאלגוריתם Grover. השלב הראשון של אלגוריתם Grover הוא שלב האתחול שמכניס את Q לסופרפוזיציה
אחידה על כל מחרוזות ה-n ביטים, ורק כדי לתת למצב הזה שם שקל לזהות אקרא לו
ket u. u זה קיצור של uniform. חשוב לצורך הניתוח שנציין קודם ש
מצב אחיד זה ket u מוכל בתת-המרחב הנפרש על ידי שני הוקטורים ket A0 ו-ket
A1. בפרט, אם לוקחים את הצירוף הלינארי של שני המצבים האלה שמוצג כאן על המסך, מקבלים את ket
u. עכשיו, המפתח לכל הניתוח הוא העובדה שמצב Q נשאר ב
תת-המרחב הדו-ממדי הזה לא משנה כמה פעמים מפעילים את פעולת Grover. אז הכול הולך
להסתכם במה שקורה בתת-מרחב דו-ממדי. עכשיו בואו נראה מה פעולת Grover עושה, ובפרט מה היא
עושה לוקטורים בתת-המרחב הדו-ממדי הנפרש על ידי ket A0 ו-ket
A1. מועיל לדמיין ש-G מפוצל לשני חלקים. חלק אחד הוא gate
ZF והחלק השני הוא gate Zor סנדוויץ' בין שתי שכבות של gate-י
Hadamard. הנה ההגדרה של ZF מקודם, וזה די ישיר מההגדרה הזו לראות שה
פעולה שלו על שני המצבים שלנו, הסופרפוזיציות האחידות של לא-פתרונות ופתרונות, היא פשוט לשים סימן מינוס
לפני ket A1. ובכן, שום דבר לא קורה ל-ket A0, וזה כל מה שצריך לדעת
על ZF לצורך הניתוח הזה. לגבי החלק השני שהוא
gate Zor סנדוויץ' בין שתי שכבות של gate-י Hadamard, נתחיל בלהיזכר איך Zor מוגדר. דרך אחת לרשום את זה
היא כמוצג על המסך, זה אותו ביטוי כמו קודם, ודרך אחרת לבטא את זה בסימון
דירק היא ככה, ואפשר לוודא את הביטוי הזה פשוט על ידי חשיבה על איך הפעולה ב
צד ימין פועלת על מצבי בסיס סטנדרטי. בפרט, היא לא עושה כלום למצב כולו-אפסים וכל
מצב בסיס סטנדרטי אחר מקבל סימן מינוס, מה שעולה בקנה אחד עם ההגדרה של Z-
or. אז אם עושים סנדוויץ' לפעולה הזו בין שתי שכבות של gate-י Hadamard, מקבלים ביטוי דומה חוץ
מזה שבמקום מצב הבסיס הסטנדרטי כולו-אפסים עכשיו יש לנו את הסופרפוזיציה האחידה ket u, וזה בגלל ש-H טנסור
n ממיר את מצב הבסיס הסטנדרטי כולו-אפסים ל-ket u, וגם H טנסור n הוא השחלוף הצמוד של עצמו אז זה עובד בצורה דומה
כשפועל מימין על ה-bra ולא ה-ket. ועכשיו אנחנו הולכים להבין
מה G עושה לשני הוקטורים שלנו A0 ו-A1 באמצעות העובדות שזה עתה
ציינו. נתחיל עם A0. קודם נציב את הביטוי
שקיבלנו עבור gate Zor סנדוויץ' בין שתי שכבות של gate-י Hadamard. אז אפשר להשתמש בעובדה ש-ZF לא עושה כלום
ל-ket A0, אז אפשר להיפטר מפעולת ZF. ועכשיו באמצעות התיאור
של ket u שיש לנו כאן למעלה, יחד עם העובדה ש-ket A0 ו-ket A1 הם וקטורי יחידה אורתוגונליים, אפשר לחשב
את המכפלה של ה-bra הזה וה-ket הזה, ומה שמקבלים הוא שורש מספר הלא-פתרונות
חלקי N. אפשר להשתמש בעובדה הזו כדי להעריך מה מקבלים, ועל ידי הצבת הביטוי שלנו ל-ket u ו
פישוט, מקבלים את התוצאה הסופית שמוצגת כאן על המסך. בפרט, שימו לב שה
וקטור הזה מוכל בתת-המרחב הדו-ממדי הנפרש על ידי ket A0 ו-ket A1 כפי שהצעתי קודם, ו
יתר על כן המקדמים במקרה הם מספרים ממשיים. כמו תמיד, בדקו את זה בקצב
שלכם אם תבחרו לעשות את זה. אני נוטה לעבור על דברים כאלה מהר בסרטונים האלה עם
הציפייה שתעצרו את הסרטון כדי לתת לזה קצת מחשבה אם תבחרו לעשות את זה. אז בואו ננקה את זה כדי
שנוכל לשמור את התוצאה הסופית לאחר כך. ועכשיו נעשה משהו דומה לוקטור ket
A1. אפשר להשתמש באותו ביטוי של G כמו קודם, והפעם gate ZF מזריק
סימן מינוס, שכאן משתקף בעובדה שהחלפנו את שני האיברים בפעולה שב
סוגריים. אז ממשיכים בדרך מאוד דומה והתוצאה הסופית דומה חוץ מזה ששני המקדמים
מוחלפים ועכשיו יש סימן מינוס לפני אחד מהם, שזה פשוט איך שהאלגברה יוצאת. ושוב
אפשר לבדוק את זה בקצב שלכם. שימו לב שגם הפעם יש לנו צירוף לינארי ממשי של שני הוקטורים שלנו ket A0 ו
ket A1. ננקה גם את זה ונשים את התוצאה הסופית יחד עם האחרת. ועכשיו אפשר לראות איך G
פועלת על תת-המרחב הנפרש על ידי שני הוקטורים שלנו. דרך אחת לעשות את זה היא לבטא את זה במונחי מטריצה 2 על 2 M ש
מוצגת כאן על המסך. ורק להבהיר, מה שאנחנו עושים כאן הוא שאנחנו משייכים את השורה הראשונה והעמודה
הראשונה ל-ket A0 ואת השורה והעמודה השנייה ל-ket A1. עד כה בסדרה
באמת השתמשנו במטריצות רק כדי לתאר איך פעולות עובדות על מצבי בסיס סטנדרטי, אבל זה נפוץ להשתמש במטריצות
כדי לתאר את הפעולות של העתקות לינאריות על קבוצות שונות של וקטורים, לא רק מצבי בסיס סטנדרטי. וכאן אנחנו מדברים על מה שהפעולה G עושה
לוקטורים ket A0 ו-ket A1. אפשר להגיד עוד על מה G עושה לוקטורים ב
פרישה של ket A0 ו-ket A1 אם מסתכלים מקרוב על המטריצה M הזו, ובפרט מה שנמצא הוא
ש-M היא מטריצת סיבוב, כלומר שהפעולה שלה על המרחב הדו-ממדי הזה ניתנת לתיאור כסיבוב בזווית
קבועה כלשהי. יש כמה דרכים שונות לראות את זה, ואחת היא לשים לב
שהמטריצה M הזו ניתנת לביטוי כריבוע של מטריצה שנראית קצת יותר פשוטה. אולי קשה לזהות את זה אם רק
מסתכלים על M לבד, אבל זה לא משהו שצריך לגלות לבד, רק צריך לוודא את זה, ואפשר לעשות את זה על ידי פשוט
העלאת המטריצה בצד ימין בריבוע. דרך אחרת לרשום את המטריצה בצד ימין, בלי הריבוע, היא
כמוצגת על המסך, וזו הדרך הטיפוסית לתאר סיבוב בזווית נתונה תטא כ
מטריצה. הזווית המדויקת שבה אנחנו מסובבים היא ארכסינוס של שורש מספר
הפתרונות חלקי N. ואגב, בגלל שזו הפעם הראשונה שאנחנו רואים את זה, אציין ש
הזווית הזו מאוד חשובה. היא הולכת להמשיך להופיע ככל שנמשיך עם
הניתוח הזה. הארגומנט של הארכסינוס הוא מספר בין 0 ל-1, וספציפית הדרך שאנחנו
מפרשים את הארכסינוס כאן היא שזו הזווית בין 0 ל-פאי חלקי 2 שנותנת לנו את הארגומנט כשלוקחים
את הסינוס. אז זו דרך אחת לחשוב על המטריצה הזו שהעלינו בריבוע כדי לקבל
M, ובגלל שהעלאה בריבוע של המטריצה זה אותו דבר כמו להפעיל אותה פעמיים, רואים ש-M ניתנת לכתיבה לחלופין כ
סיבוב לא בזווית של תטא אלא ב-2 כפול תטא, כי על ידי העלאה בריבוע מסובבים בזווית תטא
פעמיים. דרך אחרת לוודא את כל זה אגב, למקרה שזה מועיל, היא להתחיל מהביטוי הסופי הזה של M
ולהשתמש בנוסחאות הזווית הכפולה מטריגונומטריה כדי לקבל את הביטוי המקורי של
M. וזהו הביטוי של M שמתאר את הפעולה של G על תת-המרחב הנפרש על ידי ket A0 ו-ket A1 ש
הולך להיות הכי שימושי מכאן ואילך. עכשיו חוזרים לאלגוריתם Grover עצמו. אחרי
שלב האתחול אבל לפני שמבצעים הפעלות כלשהן של G, מצב הרגיסטר Q של n qubit-ים שלנו הוא ket u, ה
סופרפוזיציה האחידה על כל מחרוזות ה-n ביטים. והנה אותו ביטוי של ket u במונחי ket A0 ו
ket A1 כמו קודם, אבל עכשיו שזיהינו את הזווית תטא הזו, רואים שאפשר
לכתוב לחלופין את ket u כקוסינוס תטא כפול ket A0 פלוס סינוס תטא כפול ket
A1. זה ברור למקדם של ket A1, ולמקדם השני רק צריך לשים לב שגודל A0 פלוס
גודל A1 הוא N, ואז אפשר פשוט לקבל את זה מטריגונומטריה בסיסית. אז זה המצב
שמתחילים איתו, ובפעם הראשונה שמפעילים G מסובבים בזווית של 2 כפול תטא, אז הזווית הכוללת נהיית 3 כפול
תטא. ואם מפעילים G שוב הזווית עולה ל-5 תטא כי למעשה סובבנו בזווית נוספת
של 2 תטא, וכן הלאה. אז אחרי T הפעלות של G אפשר לייצג את
המצב שמקבלים כפי שמוצג על המסך, כאשר הזווית של המצב שלנו שווה ל-(2T פלוס 1) כפול תטא. זה 2 כפול תטא
לכל הפעלה של G יחד עם תטא נוסף כי זה המצב שהתחלנו בו.
אפשר גם לחשוב על פעולת פעולת Grover במונחים גאומטריים, וזה עוזר לשפוך קצת אור על איך
היא עובדת ולמה ההשפעה שלה היא לסובב את מצב הרגיסטר Q. הנה הרעיון המרכזי. פעולת
Grover היא הרכבה של שני החלקים שכבר זיהינו. אחד הוא ZF והשני הוא Zor סנדוויץ' בין
שתי שכבות של gate-י Hadamard. שני החלקים האלה הם
שיקופים, וכשמרכיבים שני שיקופים מקבלים סיבוב. אז בואו נראה איך זה עובד ב
יתר פירוט. קודם נתמקד ב-ZF ונגביל את תשומת הלב שלנו ל
אותו תת-מרחב דו-ממדי שדיברנו עליו, כלומר זה שנפרש על ידי ket A0 ו-ket
A1. כפי שכבר ציינו, הפעולה של ZF על המרחב הזה די פשוטה. היא לא
עושה כלום ל-ket A0 ושמה סימן מינוס לפני ket A1. זהו שיקוף, וספציפית
זה שיקוף סביב הקו המקביל ל-ket A0, שנקרא לו L1 רק כדי לתת לו
שם. כדי לראות למה זה שיקוף, מועיל לצייר תמונה. הנה שני הוקטורים שלנו ket
A0 ו-ket A1 שהם וקטורי יחידה אורתוגונליים, ואפשר לחשוב על המסך כמורכב מכל הצירופים
הלינאריים הממשיים של שני הוקטורים האלה. אז העיגול מייצג את כל וקטורי היחידה שעבורם המקדמים של
שני הוקטורים האלה הם מספרים ממשיים. הנה הקו L1 שמקביל ל-ket A0, ואם שוקלים
וקטור שרירותי כלשהו S על העיגול הזה, אז ההשפעה של הפעלת ZF היא לשקף סביב הקו הזה כפי שמומחש על
המסך, פשוט כי לא עושים כלום ל-ket A0 ושמים סימן מינוס לפני ket
A1. במקרה המיוחד ש-S הוא ket A0 למשל, שום דבר לא קורה כשמבצעים את השיקוף הזה, וכש-S הוא
ket A1, השיקוף לוקח אותנו עד למינוס ket A1, וזה עקבי עם הפעולה של ZF. אז ZF הוא
שיקוף שאפשר לדמיין כפי שיש לנו כאן. החלק השני של G, שהוא Zor
סנדוויץ' בין שתי שכבות של gate-י Hadamard, ניתן לביטוי כ-2 כפול ket u bra u מינוס מטריצת הזהות, כפי ש
כבר ראינו. ושוב, זהו שיקוף, הפעם סביב הקו L2 המקביל ל-ket u ולא ket
A0. אפשר לדמיין את הפעולה הזו בצורה דומה ל-ZF. הנה הוקטור ket u
היפותטית, אז זה הקו L2 המקביל ל-ket u, ושוב הפעולה על וקטור שרירותי S היא לשקף
אותו סביב הקו, שהוא L2 במקרה הזה.
ולבסוף, כפי שהזכרתי קודם, בכל פעם שמרכיבים שני שיקופים מקבלים סיבוב, וספציפית זה
סיבוב בפעמיים הזווית שבין קווי השיקוף. אז בואו נצייר תמונה דומה
למה שהיה לנו קודם. הנה קווי השיקוף שהזווית תטא ביניהם,
ואם לוקחים וקטור שרירותי S, משקפים סביב הקו הראשון L1 ו
אז משקפים סביב הקו השני L2, אז ההשפעה הכוללת תהיה לסובב את הוקטור S בזווית של פעמיים תטא.
וזה משהו שנכון באופן כללי, ואפשר לנסות את זה על כמה דוגמאות נוספות משלכם כדי לראות שזה אכן הדרך שזה
עובד. בכל מקרה, בתקווה שזה עוזר לכם לקבל קצת אינטואיציה למה לפעולת Grover יש את ההשפעה של סיבוב
וקטורים. עכשיו נפנה לנושא של בחירת מספר האיטרציות T באלגוריתם
Grover. נתחיל בלחשוב על איך הניתוח שראינו עד כה, שחושף מה פעולת Grover עושה
כשמפעילים אותה שוב ושוב על הסופרפוזיציה האחידה, קשור למשימה שאנחנו מקווים לפתור, שהיא למצוא פתרון לבעיית החיפוש
שלנו, או במילים אחרות מחרוזת כלשהי שמוכלת בקבוצה A1. בקיצור, אנחנו בעצם הולכים לקבוע
מטרה ואז להבין כמה פעמים להפעיל את פעולת Grover כדי להגיע קרוב למטרה
הזו. קודם נדמיין שיש לנו מצב כלשהו שהוא צירוף לינארי של שני הוקטורים שלנו ket A0 ו-ket
A1. אם מבצעים מדידת בסיס סטנדרטי על המצב הזה נקבל תוצאה בקבוצה A1 שהיא
קבוצת הפתרונות לבעיית החיפוש שלנו, בהסתברות שווה לריבוע הערך המוחלט של כל מקדם שיש לנו ל-ket A1. ועבור
הוקטור שמוצג על המסך, המקדם הזה הוא בטא. זה אינטואיטיבי: אם היינו מודדים את המצב ket A0
היינו מקבלים לא-פתרון אקראי, ואם היינו מודדים ket A1 היינו מקבלים פתרון אקראי. אז אם מודדים את המצב
הזה כאן, נקבל לא-פתרון אקראי בהסתברות ריבוע הערך המוחלט של אלפא ופתרון אקראי
בהסתברות ריבוע הערך המוחלט של בטא. אבל אפשר גם פשוט להקדיש רגע ולחשב את זה. הנה המצב כתוב
כך שאפשר לראות מהם הרכיבים של הוקטור הזה עבור מצבי בסיס סטנדרטי. אז אם מודדים, אלו הן ה
הסתברויות לקבל כל תוצאה אפשרית, וכדי לקבל את ההסתברות לקבל פתרון סוכמים את ה
הסתברויות לכל הפתרונות האפשריים, מה שנותן לנו את ריבוע הערך המוחלט של בטא כ
צפוי. עכשיו, כבר ניתחנו מה קורה כשמריצים את אלגוריתם Grover ל-T איטרציות. מקבלים את המצב ש
מוצג כאן על המסך. אז בגלל שהמקדם של ket A1 הוא הסינוס
של (2T פלוס 1) כפול תטא, כאשר הנה שוב הזווית החשובה מאוד תטא,
נראה פתרון בהסתברות סינוס בריבוע של (2T פלוס 1) כפול
תטא. היינו רוצים לעשות את ההסתברות הזו גדולה, אידיאלית כמה שיותר קרובה ל-1. אז ככל שאנחנו מסובבים את
וקטור המצב על ידי חזרה על G, נחשוב על ket A1 כמצב המטרה וננסה
לבחור T כך שנגיע קרוב למצב הזה. וכשעושים את זה, טוב לזכור שהיינו רוצים גם
למזער את T כי זה מספר השאילתות שצריך לעשות. אז אם רוצים לעשות את ה
הסתברות הזו קרובה ל-1 ולמזער T, הגיוני לנסות לעשות את הזווית של וקטור המצב שלנו קרובה לפאי חלקי 2 כי
זו הזווית הקטנה ביותר שעושה את ריבוע הסינוס גדול. אז זו בעצם ההזדמנות הראשונה שלנו לעשות את ההסתברות גדולה ככל ש
מסובבים את וקטור המצב. עכשיו, אי אפשר בהכרח לפגוע בדיוק בזווית פאי חלקי 2 כי T חייב
להיות מספר שלם, אבל אם חושבים על זה בקירוב ופותרים עבור T כאילו זה היה אי-שוויון, רואים שאידיאלית
בחירת T להיות פאי חלקי 4 כפול תטא מינוס חצי הגיונית.
אבל כמובן T חייב להיות מספר שלם לא-שלילי, אז מה שנעשה הוא
לקחת את המספר השלם הקרוב ביותר למה שאנחנו מדמיינים כערך האידיאלי, שהוא הרצפה של פאי חלקי 4 כפול
תטא. לקיחת הרצפה אגב פשוט אומרת שזורקים כל חלק שברי, אז במילים אחרות זה המספר
השלם הגדול ביותר שקטן מ-או שווה למה שלוקחים את הרצפה שלו. לפי הביטוי הזה, אם
הערך האידיאלי מתברר כבדיוק באמצע בין שני מספרים שלמים, נעגל למעלה, אבל זה באמת לא ישנה בכלל לצורך
השיעור הזה. אז מכאן ואילך אנחנו הולכים להתמקד בבחירה הספציפית הזו של
T, אבל יש עוד שיקול חשוב אחד שצריך לעשות, והוא שהציון הזה של T תלוי
בכמה פתרונות יש, כי הזווית תטא תלויה במספר
הפתרונות. מכאן ואילך אני אשתמש באות S להתייחס למספר הפתרונות, או במילים אחרות גודל
הקבוצה A1, רק לצורך נוחות. בכל מקרה, העניין הוא שהביטוי
שלנו ל-T, הערך שאנחנו משערים שצריך להיות טוב, תלוי בתטא ותטא תלוי ב-S שהוא
גודל הקבוצה A1. זו לא בעיה אם יודעים מראש כמה פתרונות יש, אבל
אם לא יודעים כמה פתרונות יש מראש, אנחנו לא יודעים מה תטא ואז אי אפשר לבחור T ככה
ונצטרך לעשות משהו אחר. אחזור למצב שבו לא יודעים את S קצת מאוחר יותר, אבל כדי
להתחיל נתמקד במצב שבו כן יודעים כמה פתרונות יש, ונתחיל עם חיפוש יחיד
שבו מובטח שיש פתרון יחיד אחד שאנחנו
מחפשים. הזכרתי את בעיית החיפוש היחיד כדוגמה לבעיית שאילתות בשיעור
5. הקלט הוא פונקציה f מ-n ביטים לביט אחד, יש מחרוזת n-ביטים יחידה
שגורמת ל-F להתחשב ל-1, והמטרה היא לפלוט את המחרוזת הזו. אז
זה שקול לבעיית החיפוש הלא-מובנה שדיברנו עליה, אבל עם ההבטחה שיש בדיוק פתרון אחד. ולמעשה זו
הגרסה היחידה של בעיית החיפוש ש-Lov Grover שקל במאמרו המקורי מ-1996 שהציג את אלגוריתם
Grover. לחיפוש יחיד יש לנו ש-S שווה ל-1, ולכן הזווית החשובה תטא שווה לארכסינוס
של שורש 1 חלקי N. כש-N גדול, הערך הזה הוא בקירוב שורש 1 חלקי N, ו
זה בגלל שעבור זוויות קטנות יותר ויותר, פונקציית הסינוס מתחילה להיראות יותר ויותר כמו פונקציית
הזהות. אם מציבים את הקירוב הזה בבחירה שלנו ל-T רואים ש-T הוא בקירוב הרצפה
של פאי חלקי 4 כפול שורש N. זה טוב כי אנחנו בדרך להשתמש ב-O גדול של שורש N
שאילתות, אם כי בשלב הזה עדיין לא בדקנו בדיוק כמה טוב האלגוריתם
מבצע. בואו נסתכל על דוגמה שבה N גדולה הוא 128, שזה 2 בחזקת 7. אז
הפונקציה f שלנו היא מ-7 ביטים לביט אחד, ואנחנו מניחים שיש פתרון יחיד. אבל כדי להבין כמה
טוב האלגוריתם עובד, באמת צריך להתעסק רק עם הזווית תטא שאפשר לחשב. היא
בערך 0.0885 רדיאנים, שזה קצת יותר מ-5 מעלות. ואם מציבים את הערך הזה ב
ביטוי שלנו ל-T, מקבלים 8. אז אנחנו חושבים על מה שקורה כשמחפשים פתרון יחיד מתוך 128
אפשרויות באמצעות 8 שאילתות. אפשר לצייר תמונה שממחישה איך המצב משתנה עם
הזמן ככל שמבצעים איטרציות של פעולת Grover. כמו קודם יש לנו את המצבים ket
A0 ו-ket A1, ובמקרה הספציפי הזה כלומר חיפוש יחיד, ket A1 הוא למעשה מצב הבסיס הסטנדרטי
המתאים לפתרון היחיד יהיה מה שיהיה, בעוד ket A0 הוא הסופרפוזיציה האחידה על כל
המחרוזות מלבד הפתרון היחיד. הנה הסופרפוזיציה האחידה על כל המחרוזות ש
אפשר לכתוב כקוסינוס תטא כפול ket A0 פלוס סינוס תטא כפול ket A1, וזה הגיוני ש-ket A0
ו-ket u קרובים במקרה הזה, כי כמו שזה עתה ציינו, ket A0 הוא
כמעט הסופרפוזיציה האחידה על כל המחרוזות. חסרה רק מחרוזת אחת, והיא הפתרון היחיד. הפעלת G שוב מסובבת ב
2 תטא נוספים, אז כאן אנחנו אחרי שתי איטרציות. הנה שלוש, 4, 5, 6, 7 ו-8.
ועכשיו רואים שאנחנו די קרובים ל-ket A1, אז אם עוצרים ומודדים בנקודה הזו יהיה סביר מאוד שנקבל
את הפתרון היחיד. ולמעשה, במקרה הזה יש רק בערך חצי אחוז סיכוי שלא נקבל את הפתרון
היחיד. מצד שני, אם היינו ממשיכים להפעיל את פעולת Grover יותר משמונה הפעמים המומלצות,
אז ההסתברות לקבל פתרון הייתה יורדת בחזרה, ועם הזמן היא הייתה מתנדנדת ככל שהמצב הולך סביב
העיגול. אז חשוב שנעצור את האיטרציות בזמן הנכון אם רוצים להצליח בהסתברות
גבוהה. בואו נחשוב על ההסתברות שהבחירה שלנו ל-T חושפת את הפתרון היחיד באופן כללי יותר, לערכים שונים של
N. נכתוב p(N,1) כדי לסמן את ההסתברות שאלגוריתם Grover מצליח למצוא פתרון יחיד
לכל ערך אפשרי של N. ה-1 מציין פתרון אחד, ונרחיב את הסימון הזה למספרים אחרים של פתרונות
בקרוב. הנה טבלה של ההסתברויות האלה עבור חזקות קטנות של 2. זה מתחיל עם N שווה ל-2 וה
הסתברות היא חצי, מה שלא כל כך טוב. אבל אז עבור N שווה ל-4 ההסתברות היא בדיוק 1, אז זה ממש עובד
בצורה מושלמת במקרה הזה. זה תרגיל מצוין אגב לעבור במפורש על איך שני המקרים האלה עובדים,
במיוחד המקרה ש-N שווה ל-4. במקרה הזה מחפשים פתרון אחד מתוך ארבע אפשרויות,
צריך שאילתה אחת בלבד, וזה עובד בצורה מושלמת. ככל ש-N גדל כן רואים תנודות מסוימות, ההסתברויות
עולות ויורדות קצת, אבל נראה שהן מתקרבות ל-1. ואכן זה נכון, ניתן להוכיח
אנליטית שההסתברות תמיד לפחות 1 מינוס 1 חלקי N. אז זה טוב.
האלגוריתם לא מושלם, אנחנו לא מובטחים לקבל פתרון, אבל זה די סביר, במיוחד עבור ערכים גדולים
של N, וגם האנומליה המעניינת מאוד שקורה כש-N שווה ל-4.
צריך גם לציין שתמיד אפשר להריץ את כל האלגוריתם כולל המדידות כמה פעמים שנרצה, ואם כל אחת מההרצות
מצליחה נקבל פתרון. אז אם ההסתברויות האלה לא מספיק טובות, אפשר בקלות להגביר אותן על ידי פשוט הרצת
האלגוריתם שוב. למעשה, אפילו אם כל ההסתברויות האלה היו שוות לחצי למשל, עדיין היה לנו
אלגוריתם חיפוש שימושי. עכשיו בואו נשקול מה קורה כשיש מספר
פתרונות. נתחיל עם דוגמה דומה לקודם, שוב N שווה ל-128, אבל הפעם
מספר הפתרונות S הוא 4 ולא 1. שוב אפשר לחשב תטא ו-T ו
מקבלים שתטא הוא בערך 0.177 או קצת יותר מ-10 מעלות, ו-T הוא
4 הפעם. אז הזווית היא בערך פעמיים הערך מהדוגמה הקודמת, ו-T הוא חצי ממה שהיה.
אפשר לצייר תמונה כמו קודם. הנה איפה
מתחילים. הנה איטרציה אחת, שתיים, שלוש וארבע. הפעם אנחנו מאוד קרובים ל-ket
A1, וההסתברות לקבל פתרון הפעם מתבררת כגדולה מ
99.9%. אבל אם לא היינו יודעים טוב יותר וחשבנו שיש רק פתרון אחד, היינו לוקחים T להיות 8 כמו
קודם, היינו מסובבים כמעט כל הדרך סביב למינוס ket A0, וזה היה מוביל להסתברות מאוד קטנה של
הצלחה. אז זו דוגמה נוספת שמראה שיש בחירות טובות של T ובחירות רעות של T, וכאן רואים
שבחירה טובה עבור S שווה ל-1 מתבררת כבחירה מאוד רעה עבור S שווה ל-4. אבל בהנחה שאנחנו כן יודעים את S מ
ראש ובוחרים T לפי המפרט שלנו, מתברר שאלגוריתם Grover ימצא פתרון
בהסתברות לפחות 1 מינוס S חלקי N, ולעתים קרובות זה יהיה הרבה יותר גדול מזה. זה גם לפחות S חלקי N אבל
זה בעצם הרבה פחות מעניין. מה שיותר מעניין הוא שככל שהשבר S חלקי N קטן, החסם
על הסתברות ההצלחה מתקרב יותר ויותר לאחד. עכשיו כפי שכבר העירתי כמה
פעמים, המספר T מייצג לא רק את מספר האיטרציות של פעולת Grover שאנחנו מבצעים אלא גם את מספר
השאילתות שאנחנו עושים. אז איך המספר הזה תלוי ב-S וב-
N? קודם נתחיל עם העובדה שארכסינוס של X הוא תמיד לפחות X, בתנאי ש-X בין 0 ל-1.
זה די קל להראות אם במקרה מכירים את טור טיילור של פונקציית הארכסינוס, אבל יש דרכים אחרות להסיק את זה ואנחנו פשוט
הולכים לקבל את זה כנתון כי זה נכון. זה אומר שתטא הוא לפחות שורש S חלקי
N, ובהתאם T הוא לכל היותר פאי חלקי 4 כפול שורש N חלקי
S. אז זה בעצם אפילו טוב יותר מ-O גדול של שורש N. ככל ש-S גדול יותר בהשוואה
ל-N, פחות שאילתות אנחנו צריכים לעשות. ובמובן מסוים זה לא מפתיע שהשבר הזה מופיע
ככה, בהינתן שההופכי שלו מגדיר את תטא, ובסופו של דבר תטא הוא באמת כל מה שחשוב עבור
הניתוח הזה. כפי שראינו זה עתה, אלגוריתם Grover עובד די טוב כשיודעים
מראש כמה פתרונות יש. אבל מה אם לא יודעים כמה פתרונות
יש? יש גישה אחת די פשוטה והיא פשוט לבחור את מספר האיטרציות
באקראי, וספציפית לבחור T באופן אחיד אקראי בין 1 לבין הרצפה של פאי חלקי 4 כפול שורש N. מתברר שזו
דרך די טובה לעשות את זה. הקצה העליון של הטווח הזה הוא בערך מספר השאילתות שהיינו בוחרים לחיפוש יחיד, ולמעשה
זה בדיוק המספר הנכון ברוב המקרים. זה כשהזווית תטא קטנה ככל האפשר, לא כולל
את המקרה הטריוויאלי שבו אין פתרונות כלל. הרעיון כאן הוא שבמקום לכוון בזהירות את וקטור המצב שלנו אל
ket A1 כמו שעשינו כשידענו כמה פתרונות יש, אנחנו בעצם מסובבים בזווית אקראית כאילו אנחנו
פשוט נותנים לוקטור המצב סיבוב אקראי. אם במקרה יש רק פתרון אחד, הסיבוב האקראי שלנו יכול לדחוף
את וקטור המצב קרוב ל-ket A1, אבל הוא גם יכול פשוט ללכת חלק מהדרך לשם. ואם במקרה יש הרבה פתרונות אז
הסיבוב האקראי שלנו יכול פוטנציאלית לשלוח את וקטור המצב סביב העיגול כמה פעמים. אז אנחנו לא מצפים שזה יחשוף
פתרון בהסתברות קרובה לאחד, אבל הסיכוי שזה יוביל לפתרון אם יש כזה מתברר כ
די טוב. זה תמיד לפחות 40%. למעשה זה לא ברור מאליו אבל זה אכן המצב.
זה בוודאי לא מזעזע כי זווית אקראית באמת הייתה נותנת סיכוי של 50% למצוא
פתרון בכל מקרה. 40% זה לא רע, וזכרו שתמיד אפשר להגביר את ההסתברות למצוא פתרון על ידי
חזרה על התהליך, תוך בחירת T באופן בלתי תלוי בכל פעם. על ידי כך הסיכויים לא למצוא
פתרון כשיש כזה יורדים באופן מעריכי במספר הפעמים שחוזרים. אז אם רוצים סיכוי של 99%
למצוא פתרון, מה שאפשר לעשות הוא להריץ את הגישה הפשוטה הזו 10 פעמים, שוב עם T שנבחר באופן בלתי תלוי בכל
פעם. באופן טבעי אם לא מוצאים פתרון פולטים אין פתרונות. אם אין פתרונות
לא נמצא כזה, ולכן במקרה הזה תמיד נפלוט את התשובה הנכונה שהיא אין פתרונות. אם יש פתרונות
אולי ניכשל למצוא כזה ובטעות נכריז שאין פתרונות, אבל ההסתברות שזה יקרה אפשר לעשות מאוד קטנה.
יש לנו גם, כפי שהזכרתי לפני כמה רגעים, שזה דורש מספר שאילתות או הערכות של f שהוא O גדול של שורש
N. אז באמצעות אלגוריתם Grover אנחנו עדיין יכולים לפתור את בעיית החיפוש בהסתברות גבוהה עם O גדול של שורש N
שאילתות, גם אם לא יודעים מראש כמה פתרונות יש. יש גם גישה יותר מתוחכמת
שיכולה להוביל להפחתה במספר השאילתות ככל שמספר הפתרונות גדל. לא אתאר אותה ב
פירוט אבל במקום זה אתמקד רק ברעיון המרכזי. מתחילים עם T גדולה שווה ל
אחד. אז מריצים את אלגוריתם Grover למספר אקראי של איטרציות אבל כאשר הגבול העליון הוא T. אז בפעם
הראשונה שמגיעים לשלב שני נריץ את אלגוריתם Grover עם איטרציה אחת, אבל T הולך
לגדול. אם מוצאים פתרון אז פולטים את הפתרון ועוצרים, ואם לא מוצאים פתרון מגדילים T
ומנסים שוב. ובשלב מסוים לפני ש-T נהיה גדול מדי נסיים את התהליך ו
נכריז שאין פתרונות. זה אותו רעיון בסיסי כמו בגישה הפשוטה שבה אנחנו
נותנים לוקטור המצב סיבובים אקראיים בעצם, אבל כאן מתחילים עם סיבובים קלים יותר קודם, כאשר T
קטן, למקרה שיש הרבה פתרונות. בדרך הזו לא נבזבז שאילתות על ידי כך שהמצב הולך סביב
ועוד סביב העיגול על ידי סיבוב חזק מדי. אבל אם זה לא עובד, כלומר לא מוצאים פתרון, מנסים שוב
אבל מסובבים קצת יותר חזק, או פוטנציאלית קצת יותר חזק. כדי שזה יעבוד, קצב
הגידול של T צריך להיבחר בקפידה, ודרך אחת לגרום לזה לעבוד היא להחליף T בתקרה של 5/4 כפול T.
אז T גדל באופן מעריכי, ואינטואיטיבית אפשר לחשוב על זה כמסובבים 25% יותר חזק בכל
פעם. וזה חשוב לניתוח ש-T גדל באופן מעריכי ככה. למה 5/4 אתם אולי שואלים? ובכן, זה
פשוט מספר שעובד, ולמעשה יש טווח של ערכים שעובדים, אבל 2 לא עובד למשל. להכפיל את T
בכל פעם זה גידול מהיר מדי כדי לנצל את מלוא היתרונות של סיבובים קלים יותר. בכל מקרה, הנקודה של השיטה היותר
מתוחכמת הזו היא שהיא נותנת את אותו חסם אסימפטוטי על מספר השאילתות שאנחנו צריכים כמו שהיה לנו קודם,
O גדול של שורש N חלקי S, אבל אנחנו לא צריכים לדעת מראש כמה פתרונות יש. ואגב,
אפשר לעצור את התהליך הזה כש-T מגיע לשורש N. אז אם אין פתרונות נגיע למסקנה הזו אחרי O גדול
של שורש N שאילתות. וככה אפשר לבחור את מספר האיטרציות באלגוריתם Grover. לסיום השיעור
אעשה רק כמה הערות קצרות על אלגוריתם Grover. קודם כל, בתוך מודל השאילתות
אלגוריתם Grover הוא אופטימלי אסימפטוטית. מה שזה אומר הוא שאי אפשר להמציא
אלגוריתם שאילתות לפתרון בעיית החיפוש, או אפילו בעיית החיפוש היחיד ספציפית, שמשתמש באסימפטוטית
פחות מ-O גדול של שורש N שאילתות במקרה הגרוע. זה משהו שאפשר להוכיח בצורה קפדנית,
ולמעשה יש כמה הוכחות ידועות לעובדה הזו. מעניין שזה היה ידוע עוד
לפני שאלגוריתם Grover התגלה. אלגוריתם Grover התאים לחסם התחתון הכבר ידוע על מספר
השאילתות הנדרש. מפעם לפעם אנשים אכן מציעים גישות שהם מאמינים שהן אסימפטוטית
עדיפות על אלגוריתם Grover, אבל תמיד יש או טעות, או הנחה על הפונקציה f ועל
האופן שבו אפשר לגשת אליה, או בעיה כלשהי אחרת שהופכת את הטענה לשגויה. אם עובדים כראוי
בתוך מודל השאילתות, אי אפשר לנצח את אלגוריתם Grover לחיפוש לא-מובנה. שנית, אלגוריתם Grover הוא
ישים באופן רחב למדי, במובן שההאצה בשורש ריבועי שאלגוריתם Grover מציע לבעיית החיפוש הלא-מובנה ניתנת ל
השגה במגוון הקשרים שונים. לדוגמה, לפעמים אפשר להשתמש באלגוריתם Grover על גבי
אלגוריתם אחר כדי לקבל שיפור ריבועי מעבר לביצועים של אותו אלגוריתם. אלגוריתם Grover גם
משמש לעתים קרובות כתת-שגרה בתוך אלגוריתמים קוונטיים אחרים. כדוגמה פשוטה אחת,
אפשר להשתמש באלגוריתם Grover כדי לקבל יתרון ריבועי על אלגוריתמים קלאסיים לבעיית המינימום שהזכרתי ב
שיעור 5. ולבסוף, הטכניקה המשמשת באלגוריתם Grover שבה יש לנו שני
שיקופים שמורכבים ומופעלים שוב ושוב כדי לסובב וקטור מצב קוונטי ניתנת להכללה בצורה
משמעותית למדי. דוגמה היא טכניקה הידועה בשם הגברת אמפליטודה, שבה תהליך
שמכליל את אלגוריתם Grover יכול להיות מיושם על אלגוריתם קוונטי אחר כדי בעצם להגביר את הסתברות ההצלחה שלו באופן ריבועי מהר יותר ממה ש
היה אפשרי באופן קלאסי. ולטכניקה הזו יש יישומים רחבים באלגוריתמים קוונטיים. אז יכול להיות נכון ש
אלגוריתם Grover לא צפוי להוביל ליתרון קוונטי פרקטי בזמן הקרוב, אם בכלל, אבל אלגוריתם Grover הוא
ללא ספק אלגוריתם קוונטי חשוב ביסודו וישים באופן רחב, והוא מייצג טכניקה כללית יותר שיש לה שימושים
רבים. וזהו לשיעור הזה וליחידה הזו בסדרה שעסקה באלגוריתמים
קוונטיים. דנו במודל השאילתות ובאיך אפשר לחבר אותו למודל חישוב יותר סטנדרטי, יחד עם
כמה מושגים יסודיים נוספים הנוגעים לאיך אפשר למדוד עלות חישובית. אז כיסינו הערכת פאזה
ופירוק לגורמים, ולבסוף אלגוריתם Grover. כפי שכבר רמזתי,
יש עוד הרבה מה ללמוד על אלגוריתמים קוונטיים, אבל בסדרה הזו נעבור לנושא אחר ביחידה הבאה. בפרט נסתכל על
הניסוח הכללי של מידע קוונטי שבו מצבים קוונטיים מיוצגים על ידי מטריצות מסוג
מסוים הידועות כמטריצות צפיפות. כפי שנראה, הניסוח הזה מתברר כמאוד שימושי ולמעשה
חיוני להבנת היבטים מסוימים של מידע קוונטי, והוא גם במקרה יפה למדי מנקודת מבט
מתמטית. אז אני מקווה שתצטרפו אליי ליחידה שלוש ולהתראות עד
אז.